FOR EVEN MORE VIOLENCE.
MICHELLE?
>> NOT GOOD TO HEAR.
THANK YOU.
>>> NOW TO THE LATEST ON THE
PANDEMIC.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
BANKING ON IMPROVING ACCESS AS A
WAY OF ENSURING 70% OF THE
COUNTRY IS VACCINATED BY JULY
4th.
RIGHT NOW, 45% OF AMERICANS HAVE
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE, AND
JUST ABOUT ONE-THIRD OF THE
NATION HAS BEEN FULLY
VACCINATED.
BUT THE NUMBER OF AMERICANS
GETTING VACCINATED IS DROPPING
OFF.
>>> TWO UPCOMING DECISIONS FROM
THE FOOD AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION
COULD PROVIDE A POSSIBLE
TURNAROUND AND GIVE THE NATION A
MUCH-NEEDED SHOT IN THE ARM.
MICHAEL GEORGE IS AT A
VACCINATION SITE HERE IN NEW
YORK WITH MORE ON THIS.
GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: MICHELLE, GOOD
MORNING.
VACCINATION RATES COULD SOON GET
A BOOST.
AS EARLY AS NEXT WEEK THE FDA IS
EXPECTED TO APPROVE THE PFIZER
VACCINE FOR TEENS 12 TO 15 YEARS
OLD, AND RESEARCH IS UNDER WAY
TO DETERMINE IF THE VACCINE IS
SAFE FOR EVEN YOUNGER CHILDREN.
16-MONTH-OLD NATHAN IS ALREADY
VACCINATED, PART OF A STUDY AT
TEXAS CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL WHERE
HIS MOTHER IS A PEDIATRIC
SUR
SURGEON.
>> HAVING UNDERSTOOD THE DATA
AND RISKS INVOLVED, WE FELT THAT
THE BENEFITS OUTWEIGH THE RISKS.
AND SO THAT WAS WHY THE DECISION
WAS CLEAR FOR ME.
>> Reporter: HIS SHOT WAS
ONE-TENTH OF AN ADULT DOSE.
>> BY THE END OF THE DAY, HE WAS
HAVING A DANCE PARTY WITH HIS
BROTHER.
EVERYTHING WAS FINE.
>> Reporter: BIG BROTHER CHARLIE
IS ENROLLED IN A STUDY FOR HIS
AGE GROUP.
>> MY YOUNGEST SON, 16, IS NOW
JUST RECENTLY FULLY VACCINATED.
>> Reporter: DR. ROCHELLE
WALENSKY IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL.
>> AND I REST EASY KNOWING MY
FAMILY WILL BE SAFE AND THAT IS
SIMPLY THE BEST MOTHER'S DAY
GIFT I COULD GET THIS YEAR.
>> Reporter: BUT NOT EVERY
CHILD'S MOTHER MAY BE EAGER TO
CELEBRATE.
LESS THAN A THIRD OF PARENTS SAY
THEY'D GET THEIR CHILDREN
VACCINATED.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT KAISER
FAMILY FOUNDATION'S COVID
VACCINATION MONITOR.
AMONG VACCINE-ELIGIBLE ADULTS,
44% HAVE NOT BEEN VACCINATED.
BUT THE OPEN-DOOR MISSION IN
OMAHA IS WORKING PATIENTLY TO
CHANGE THAT.
>> THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TREPIDATION, A LOT OF
HESITATION, A LOT OF
MISCOMMUNICATION ON THE
VACCINATION, SO WE JUST TRY TO
PROVIDE THE ACTUAL EDUCATION SO
THAT OUR GUESTS AND CONSUMERS
CAN MAKE THE RIGHT CHOICE.
>> Reporter: THE MISSION OFFERS
TRANSPORTATION, TOO, AND THIS
WEEK SAW A HUGE TURNOUT.
JOINING SITES THAT HAVE FOR
MONTHS HELPED VACCINATE MORE
THAN 100 MILLION WITH RESULTS.
>> WE'VE DEFINITELY TURNED THE
CORNER IN THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE
A NATIONAL SURGE OF CASES.
THE LEVELS OF VACCINATION WE
HAVE WILL PROTECT US FROM THAT
KIND OF EVENT.
WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO GO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
MORE STATE BY STATE OR REGIONAL
CHALLENGES.
>> Reporter: BUSINESSES, SOME ON
THE VERGE OF GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS, ARE BACK AS THE
COUNTRY SAW NEW DAILY CASES FALL
TO A SEVEN-MONTH LOW THIS WEEK.
>> PEOPLE COME AND SAY THANK GOD
YOU ARE OPEN.
I SAID, NO, THANK GOD YOU ARE
HERE.
>> Reporter: AND SAN FRANCISCO
MOVED TO THE YELLOW TIER WITH
THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION
VACCINATION RATE -- 74% OF SAN
FRANCISCO ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS
HAVE BEEN VACCINATED, MOVING
CLOSER TO THE RACE FOR HERD
IMMUNITY.
AND ON FRIDAY, PFIZER ASKED THE
FDA FOR FULL APPROVAL OF ITS
VACCINE.
RIGHT NOW IT JUST HAS EMERGENCY
APPROVAL.
IF THE FDA AGREES, IT COULD MAKE
IT EASIER FOR EMPLOYERS TO
REQUIRE THEIR WORKERS TO